6 bonjour bienvenue nous sommes en
direct sur Le Figaro.fr sur Youtube et
sachez que nous sommes à la veille de
l'événement cinéma de l'année oui Avatar
2 et dans les salles ce mercredi alors
c'est toujours la même chose grande
attente égale immense déception ou
plaisir intense et nous allons voir ça
on va essayer de savoir ce que vaut ce
nouvel opus d'Avatar la voix de l'eau
Vincent Joly bonjour bonjour Thibault
grand porteur au Figaro Magazine merci
d'être ici tout va bien tout va bien bon
ben oui à la veille d'une sortie comme
ça ça peut aller bien vous êtes là parce
que vous avez traqué James Cameron je
montre d'ailleurs cet article que vous
pouvez retrouver sur le site et
d'ailleurs je l'ai mis sous la vidéo
YouTube comme ça on peut la retrouver et
puis sinon si vous aimez mieux ça
évidemment dans le Figaro Magazine je le
montre ici
on est sorti le week-end dernier
je l'ai montré sur Internet
ici vous l'avez bon comment ça s'est
passé racontez-moi ça cette traque de
James Cameron mal au début on a presque
fini par perdre espoir il y a eu un
premier rendez-vous raté à Los Angeles
ou en fait il a planté un peu tout le
monde il a même planté Disney qui
faisait une grande cérémonie à Los
Angeles où il doit être présent et puis
bah il y avait tout le monde sauf lui
parce qu'il avait décidé que il avait
trop de travail donc il est resté en
Nouvelle-Zélande pour travailler sur son
film et il a eu raison parce que le film
n'a été il travaille en Nouvelle-Zélande
il travaille en Nouvelle-Zélande et
les Canadiens d'origine oui mais voilà
et son bon alors c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est que le film a été fini
il y a très peu de temps là il sort
demain en salle mais il a été fini à
deux semaines parce que on vous dit je
me souviens c'était il y a quelques mois
il y a un mois deux mois vous me dites
je vais à Los Angeles interviewer
Cameron
alors il y a beaucoup de journalistes
comment ça se passe dans un autre il y
avait pas mal de journalistes on est
d'ailleurs certains pour le voir mais
bon il y a un moment quand on s'appelle
James Cameron on peut faire ce qu'on un
peu ce qu'on a envie de faire et puis
c'est surtout c'était pour une bonne
cause vu que c'était pour terminer son
film bien sûr et à ce moment-là vous
voyez un extrait quand même il dévoile
un extrait 11 12 minutes je crois 12
minutes dévoiler en exclusivité
distribuer de devant 3500 personnes
et c'était déjà prometteur vous êtes
rentrés vous m'avez dit ce que j'ai vu
sur 10 15 minutes hallucinant ouais bah
ça l'est et ça l'est toujours d'ailleurs
bon et ça allait sur trois heures de
film vous savez sur 3h12 de film 3h12
attention il vous a repris James Cameron
on va en parler alors vous pouvez pas le
rencontrer là-bas comment ça se passe on
vous dit vous inquiétez pas vous allez
pouvoir la voir en visio oui alors on a
eu deux rendez-vous en visio un annulé
et un autre qu'on a réussi à avoir mais
et là c'était le comble on n'avait pas
le droit de parler d'Avatar 2 ce qui en
fait c'était une visio pour en fait
parler d'une série qui fait pour
National Geographic donc c'était un peu
curieux parce que évidemment tout le
monde avait envie de lui parler que
d'Avatar 2 mais on a dû parler d'autre
chose et on s'arrange dans cette vidéo
vous êtes pas tout seul il y a plusieurs
on était quatre ou cinq d'accord donc
pas d'avatar à ce moment-là et vous
finissez par la rencontre quand même
hein
de la presse française
avec ce qu'on appelle quand même des
entretiens en tête-à-tête on avait 19
minutes chacun
pour interviewer un géant comme ça oui
mais c'est des fois
dans des grands hôtels on explique pour
les gens qui savent pas forcément et
James Cameron reçoit tous les
journalistes les uns après les autres
alors tous les journalistes pas tous
quoi
et vous devez bien ça vous êtes à la Los
Angeles pour le moment on espérait la
voir bon vous avez du temps pour parler
avec lui vous allez nous raconter ce que
vous êtes dit mais d'abord parlons
d'Avatar évidemment c'est le plus grand
succès financier le 1 de l'histoire du
cinéma
mais c'est d'ailleurs James Cameron il
est habitué à ce genre de record faut
pas oublier que en France pour parler du
marché français c'est un de ces films
qui détient le nombre de records
d'entrée c'est
avatar arrive après les Ch'tis et après
d'autres films mais il arrive quand même
bien placé je crois qu'il est à la
centième place 14 millions d'entrée
quand même arrondissement à 15 voilà
donc non c'est un c'est à chaque fois
les gens essayent de dire que ça ne va
pas marcher à chaque fois les gens
disent c'est un navire qui va couler à
chaque fois parce que le budget quand
même d'Avatar 1 300 millions d'euros oui
mais 3 milliards de bénéfices
d'entrée je pense que alors la
technologie le budget est important dans
dans le cinéma de James Cameron mais
pour le fou il y a même pas besoin de
faire le marketing du film sur le budget
qui est souvent le qui est souvent
quelque chose de brandy comme ça genre
regarder c'est un film exceptionnel qui
a coûté 250 le premier Terminator est
entier est un spectacle incroyable qui a
pas goûté beaucoup d'argent bon en tout
cas succès immense à l'époque
des c'est Cameron lui-même il écrit il
réalise il fait tout
ça ça le met dans une case de
réalisateur assez particulier c'est gros
film à gros budget souvent il y a le
réalisateur et les scénaristes à côté
même dans des plus petits films il y a
un travail de réalisateur le travail
d'écriture est un travail qui est
complètement différent on peut penser à
Quentin Tarantino quand il paraît écrit
pratiquement beaucoup ses films ça les
met dans des cases ils réalisent pas des
films
à 300 millions d'euros de budget quand
il raconte une histoire
oui ce n'est pas que du gros budget et
de la démesure non mais c'est vrai qu'on
peut souvent comparer avatar peut-être à
des films de blockbuster et de films de
super-héros c'est pas du tout ça non ça
n'a rien à voir
je sais pas si déteste ça on en a pas
parlé parce que quand on a 19 minutes
avec James Cameron honnêtement j'avais
envie de parler d'autre chose que des
que des niaiseries Marvel est qui
peuvent déferler sur nos écrans donc
voilà je sais pas si ça level c'est mais
en tout cas pour moi ça n'a vraiment
rien à voir bon on va évidemment écouter
votre avis sur cette Avatar 2 on a bien
compris que vous l'adorez mais vous
allez nous détailler ça
avatar j'ai pas l'impression que ce soit
iconique je me souviens d'une réplique
d'avatar c'est le c'est la critique
qu'on fait toujours à ce film c'est une
critique
pourquoi pas du tout vous connaissez
beaucoup de films pas iconiques dont on
parle encore 13 ans après leur sortie
qui inspire non mais prenons Titanic par
exemple
quel film est plus iconique sinon le
plus grand succès et je parle même pas
de en fait on oublie les résultats
financiers moi je vous parle de nom du
nombre de gens qui l'ont vu 14 millions
de personnes quand le film est ressorti
en France en septembre il a caracalé en
tête de du bol saucisse français vers si
c'est pas iconique moi je sais pas ce
que c'est faudra m'expliquer ce que
c'est mais vous voyez qu'il y a certains
films que personne n'a vu et tout le
monde connaît les répliques ce qu'on
connaît une réplique d'Avatar Titanic je
suis le roi du monde Terminator Albi bac
on s'en souvient si la commande si
l'iconisme d'un film est définie par le
nombre de répliques dont on se souvient
oui dans ce cas là avatar avatar est en
dessous de Titanic et de Terminator 2 et
il faut aussi se rappeler que Avatar est
peut-être pas encore
iconique parce que ben on en est par
exemple vous parliez des films de
super-héros bon c'est facile d'être
iconiques quand on a 1 2 3 4 5 films 22
films dans le cas de Marvel avatar il y
a un seul film il y en a encore quatre
rendez-vous dans 10 ou 15 ans pour voir
si ils seront ou pas devenus comme vous
dites iconique pour moi ils le sont déjà
alors justement James Cameron avait pris
le temps entre Titanic et avatar il
avait pas fait de film il avait fait des
documentaires
là 13 ans entre avatar 1 et Avatar 2
pourquoi autant d'espace entre ces deux
films c'est une question pour pour James
Cameron si je devrais répondre à sa
place je pense que c'est parce que c'est
un réalisateur qui sait prendre son
temps et qui en l'occurrence quand il
n'a pas la technologie nécessaire pour
faire ses films de la manière dont il
l'entend ce que James Cameron est un
ingénieur dans l'âme il faut bien le
comprendre
il ne le fait pas il attend il a attendu
il s'appelle apparemment et c'est pour
ça que
désormais les avatars vont s'enchaîner
c'est ça oui je pense que là il a
atteint il a atteint il a en tout cas
Matthieu il a atteint une maturation
technologique qui à son sens apparemment
le rang assez confiant pour pour prévoir
et pour annoncer les les quatre
prochains films vous allez me donner
évidemment Vincent votre avis sur Avatar
2 vous réagissez sur le Figaro.fr sur
Youtube je transmets vos questions à
Vincent pour cet événement demain
mercredi 14 décembre avec la sortie
d'Avatar 2 la voix de l'eau c'est ça le
titre officiel je reviens sur cette
discussion avec Cameron à l'hôtel vous
êtes au Bristol vous avez parlé
technique c'est ça il a parlé peut-être
que moi je suis comme beaucoup de gens
d'ailleurs qui vont aller voir le film
demain la technique c'est quelque chose
qui est réservé normalement aux
coulisses mais dans le cas de Cameron
c'est forcément intéressant parce que
comme à chacun de ces films il
révolutionne il inv facile il a il est
pionnier sur l'utilisation de
technologie c'est vrai que c'est un peu
dommage de se priver de ça avec lui
alors vous le dites dans votre article
c'est un maître de précision dans les
mots vous lui parlez de la durée du film
ils vont reprendre mais il est précis
expliquez la raison comme un journaliste
vous arrivez pas et puis évidemment la
question l'éternel poncive je lui dis
mais alors c'est pas trop long est-ce
que vous avez beaucoup coupé
3h15 bien sûr on en fait tous trois
heures quinze et là il me reprend il me
fait non non alors nous sommes à 3h02
avec 7 minutes de générique ah oui c'est
précis bon
on est au point de réinventer le cinéma
Cameron d'une certaine manière d'un
point de vue technique parce que la 3D
par exemple c'est lui qui l'invente et
qu'il la met sur le devant de la scène
avec Avatar ah non non la 3D elle est 10
depuis un des décennies dans le cinéma
pourquoi après lui tout le monde s'est
mis à faire de la 3D avant pas grand
monde bah alors toute chose déjà parce
que je pense que mon premier avatar il y
avait une 3D qui était réellement
aboutie et il a pensé son film pour être
en 3D contrairement à tous les studios
qui ont essayé de s'engouffrer derrière
le succès d'Avatar en se disant le
succès d'Avatar c'est forcément la 3D et
donc ils ont mis tous les films en 3D
simplement quand il y a un mauvais film
qui est pas pensé construit pour être en
3D déjà un ça marche pas et puis en fait
ça prouve bien que ce qui a conquis le
public n'est pas que la 3D et n'est pas
que les effets visuels il a aussi une
manière de filmer sous l'eau vous dites
ça aussi il revient aux sources parce
que un de ses premiers films
qui étaient disparait déjà sous l'eau
mais oui alors lui il dit ça n'a aucun
rapport mais James Cameron est un
explorateur en plus d'être un cinéaste
il a d'ailleurs fait Titanic je pense
uniquement pour se payer le luxe d'aller
retrouver les pas avant
je pense alors là il nous explique que
toutes les scènes dans l'eau qui sont
quand même parmi les scènes les plus
belles du film photos
dans votre article il y a beaucoup de
la voie de l'eau attention on n'est
jamais
il dit que ça n'a rien à voir avec sa
passion pour la plongée sous-marine et
que il l'aurait fait le film quoi qu'il
arrive comme ça alors là la grande
innovation vous avez m'expliquer ça
c'est de filmer en HFR HFR iPhone red en
bel anglais d'accord alors expliquez-moi
et bien c'est en termes pour le Prophète
c'est assez simple quand vous regardez
un film en l'occurrence n'importe où on
va dire que on est sur une base de 24
images par seconde là beaucoup de films
ont été tournés en 48 sur mon portable
c'est du 48 alors ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que je mon oeil voit plus
d'image bon sans le savoir évidemment on
voit la différence ou pas on voit la
différence souvent ça peut déranger les
gens parce que les gens peuvent trouver
de l'image un peu trop métallique un peu
trop nette un peu trop fluide un peu
trop rapide d'accord voilà c'est un
format qui peut pas déranger lui déjà
c'est le premier à tourner en HFR en 48
images par seconde un Peter Jackson l'a
fait notamment sur le film Le Hobbit
d'ailleurs il le rappelle là il le fait
parce que en fait pour lui ça lui permet
de gommer certains défauts de la 3D
d'accord voilà ça permet notamment il
explique aussi beaucoup mieux que moi
dans dans l'article de d'avoir une 3D
qui est plus agréable à regarder alors
je lis ce qu'il vous dit bon c'est
compliqué
il faut analyser la manière dont la
perception humaine fonctionne par
rapport au déplacement horizontal
d'objets ou celle dont l'effet parallaxe
agit autour des éléments verticaux quand
vous avez de grands personnages mince et
bleu qui bouger rapidement sur l'écran
en 3D ça peut vite devenir
stroboscopique
alors là c'est fascinant c'est à dire
que tout est pensé pour le spectateur et
le spectacle le spectateur en pleinement
dans l'histoire grâce à la technique
c'est évident mais je pense que en fait
à la base quand même du cinéma
les gens qui s'intéressent à James
Cameron on réalise assez rapidement
c'est que il est cinéaste mais il est
aussi ingénieur d'ailleurs son père est
un ingénieur et sa mère est une artiste
il a eu le meilleur des deux alors pour
la pour la suite dans cette continuité
il me reste servir d'algorithme c'est à
dire
en fait donc tout le film n'a pas été
tourné en 48 c'est là où ça devient un
peu compliqué et c'est là où on parle
cuisine alors je pense que les gens qui
vont aller voir le film demain vont
peut-être s'en [ __ ] mais c'est quand
même intéressant c'était il a pas il a
pas choisi de tourner tout le film en 48
images par seconde certains plans
ils peuvent pas être vu parce que ça
donne un effet stroboscope exactement
très beau mot
la la ce qui me disait c'est que 90% du
temps il avait fait le bon choix sur
quel plan elle est tournée comment il a
fait quand même il admet 10% d'erreurs
bon et donc ce qui a nécessité de
retourner des plans dans un format
particulier et il me disait que il
réfléchissait à faire écrire un
algorithme qui pourrait donc confier à
une machine le soin de décider
[Musique]
n'avait vu venir ce qu'il va proposer
aux gens à partir de demain
parlez-moi du pitch ça parle de quoi cet
avatar évidemment sans nous dévoiler la
fin mais alors ça parle de quoi ça prend
par la main le spectateur c'est à dire
que je pense que beaucoup de gens
peuvent aller voir Avatar demain sans
avoir vu le premier d'accord il y a
toute une introduction d'ailleurs qui
est assez qui est assez bien faite qui
qui remet un peu dans les événements du
premier
et puis après
cette avatar là se concentre on peut le
dire je pense sur l'importance de la
famille c'est à dire une phrase de la de
la bande-annonce une phrase qui
peut-être deviendra iconique pour vous
Thibault je le souhaite à James Cameron
et notre famille est une forteresse
voilà et c'est un on voit que James
Cameron est un père parce que on voit à
quel point il a eu à coeur dans ce volet
d'Avatar de raconter les les la
difficulté la beauté la tristesse
parfois des des liens qui existent entre
des parents et leurs enfants je lis ce
qu'on me dit sur Le Figaro.fr j'ai bien
peur de voir une grosse bouille
numérique et oui c'est une inquiétude ça
un sang comment rassurer le l'internaute
potentiellement spectateur demain en
salle d'Avatar 2 comment le rassurer bah
en lui disant d'aller le voir et puis de
se faire son opinion parce que bon c'est
bien d'avoir peur peut-être mieux
d'aller vérifier par soi-même ça coûte
un budget d'aller au cinéma c'est vrai
c'est important de dire aux gens ce
qu'ils allez voir oui tout est un budget
mais une bouillie numérique je ne pense
pas je pense que on voit énormément de
bouillie numérique là par exemple si on
parle de terme employé bouillie
numérique si on parle sur donc la
facture des effets spéciaux et des
images de synthèse qui sont proposées
demain faudra m'expliquer si ça c'est
une bouille numérique alors il y a aucun
film des cinq dernières années tu tiens
la route je t'en ai fait spécial je peux
voir ce film autrement qu'en 3D ou il
faut que parfaitement il le dit
d'ailleurs alors j'ai pas eu la place de
l'écrire mais lui il l'a vu donc il l'a
vu seulement quelques fois le film fini
il avait une fois en 3D une fois en 2D
et il dit qu'en 2D le film est
parfaitement valable d'accord mais moi
j'ai toujours peur par exemple la 3D
j'ai l'impression que c'est sombre je
vois pas grand chose est-ce que c'est
encore le cas aujourd'hui
il faudrait peut-être recommencer donc
si je vais voir Avatar je vais je vais
tout voir en couleur enfin avec la
lumière
offre tous les confort
qui surtout on va dire
exploiter toutes les toutes la richesse
technologique et technique et technique
pardon que James Cameron a mis dans son
film bon je vais voir ça je vais
demander mon cinéma de quartier de se
mettre aux normes
ça va vous devriez pas avoir de malade
pour les conscience écologique chez
James Cameron non vous l'écrivez ça
c'est important pour lui oui mais alors
c'est très vraiment très important de le
dire c'est important pour lui mais
contrairement à beaucoup chez qui c'est
du greenwashing et de la posture parce
que en ce moment ça fait bien de parler
de ça chez James Cameron c'est un
engagement de très longue date et c'est
surtout un engagement l'anime au jour le
jour dans ses projets à la fois projet
cinéma mais aussi projet documentaire
est-ce que
il pourrait faire des des films pour des
plateformes Cameron quand on voit ce
film là avatar qui est pensé pour la 3D
pour la salle parce que lui ça
l'intéresse les plateformes où il a une
tendance à les critiquer et non il n'ira
jamais non enfin en tout cas devant moi
il n'a pas critiqué les plateformes je
pense que James Cameron la démontré à 68
ans on peut lui faire confiance je pense
qu'il peut tout faire je pense en
revanche que si on lui disait fait un
film pour une plateforme donc par
nécessité qui va être regardé au mieux
sur un ordinateur portable ou une télé
au pire sur un téléphone portable je
pense qu'il ne le fera pas de la même
manière il trouvera en fait
différemment son exactement pour être
adapté moi j'en suis persuadé pourquoi
il a cette débauche de moyens parce que
il a les salles de cinéma
s'il avait pas les salles de cinéma ils
s'emmerderaient pas à faire tout ça
merci beaucoup Vincent Joly est-ce que
ça va battre le record du premier opus
allez un petit Paris 14 millions
d'entrée j'en suis jamais le futur mais
je pense que les gens ont très envie de
retourner au cinéma Top Gun Maverick a
montré quelque chose cette légende
réellement envie de retourner au cinéma
très bien marché et je pense que quand
il y a un rendez-vous surtout en France
les gens ont vraiment envie de retrouver
les salles obscures c'est ce qu'il dit
d'aller lier d'aller créer un lien
intime avec une oeuvre d'art dans une
salle sombre avec des étrangers mais
mais c'est ça qu'on aime je vous
taquinais tout à l'heure mais je suis
pas loin de le penser dans le fond que
pour l'instant avatar n'est pas mythique
malgré le nombre d'entrée nous verrons
dans ce sera peut-être une preuve est-ce
que les gens se ruront dans les salles
pour un ravatar 2 est-ce que
l'engouement médiatique sera à la
hauteur de celui du premier opus en 2009
je suis en 2009 c'était impressionnant
tout le monde disait c'est une
révolution j'entends moins ça
aujourd'hui
c'est vrai mais c'est demain on pourrait
avoir tous les jours des articles
[Musique]
et à la veille évidemment de France
Maroc et puis ce soir à 20h le club
politique autour d'Yves trèsart
programme chargé et donc passionnant
vous restez avec nous bonne soirée sur
le fear live